Und einer ukrainischen Gewichtshilber-Renner, ich weiss nicht. Ja, von dem Gag hat mir es leider nur die erste Hälfte gehört. Servus. Servus! Ich will echt noch, äh, ich war völlig angeschlagen. Boah, hast du eine Dreiviertelstunde Frisbee gespielt und ich habe jetzt irgendwie die letzten drei Jahre keinen Sport mehr gemacht und das merkt man dann in solchen Situationen besonders. Ey, ich werde auch fetter, wirklich, man merkt, ich werde wirklich fetter. Ich werde wieder, ich nehme wieder zu, es ist wieder, jetzt kann man in der Karriere... Und je fetter, du wirst es besser, weil dann Gags auch wieder, weil du kannst wieder Gags über Fette machen. Ah, das ist die Frage, aber man dann. Heute zu Gast in das Podcast UFO, wir sind so stolz, sie präsentieren zu dürfen. Wir haben sie abgegriffen aus dem Nehemagazin, vor ein paar Wochen war es noch im Nehemagazin, letzte Woche bei Jimmy Fallon, davor die Woche bei Conan O'Brien, jetzt ist sie bei uns zu Gast, Hazel Brugger, meine Damen und Herren. Ja, danke für den Applaus zu Hause. Servus. Wir sind alle spontan. Die meisten hören uns zum Einschlafen, die sind jetzt nochmal aufgestanden, haben geklatscht nochmal. Ah, geil. Ja, so muss man ja nicht aufstehen, man kann auch im Liegen klatschen. Man klatscht selten im Liegen, oder? Es sei denn, man hat so eine Lampe, wo man dann anklatschen und ausklausten kann. Ich finde, man lacht auch selten im Liegen. Ich stelle mir mal vor, so glücklich zu sein, ist mein grosser Wunsch, mein Leben einmal so glücklich zu sein, dass ich lachend einschlafe. Ist dir das noch nicht passiert? Mir ist es mal, aber ich weiß nicht, ich hatte das als Kind, dass manchmal, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr das kennt, aber manchmal, wenn ihr ins Bett geht, dann ist die Bettdecke so ganz kühl. So und das Kopf ist so ganz kühl, das fühlt sich ganz toll an und einmal lag ich im bett und konnte einfach nicht fassen und musste so lachen weil ich so glücklich war in dem moment weil
dieses gefühl so dem ganzen körper irgendwie und mein onkel lag neben mir und es war einfach so
und weißt du dann bin ich glaube ich wirklich lachen eingeschlafen weil ich kann mich ab dann
nicht mehr daran erinnern was dann passiert ist ich finde es so gut wenn du in acht jahren die
stand-ups machen kannst die du willst und nicht mehr das irgendwen beweisen musst, dann kommen nur noch so Kissengags, so Dinge, die niemand lustig findet, ausser dir. Ja, stimmt schon ein bisschen. Und eineinhalb Stunden Kissengags. Na gut, hallo Hazel, dass du da bist. Hey Hazel. Du bist ja echt eine ganze tolle, schön, dass du ein Glas Wasser in der Hand und jetzt diese Augenstieren an den Horizont. Bist du zu frühst hierher gekommen? Ja. Wohnst du ganz in der Nähe hier? Nein. Aber du wohnst jetzt hier in Köln. Ich dachte erst ganz kurz, dass du irgendwie aus, weiss ich nicht, Zürich oder so plötzlich für das Podcast-UFO einfliehst. Ach, das würde ich auch machen. Wie gut das wäre. Ja, ich habe so, ich sammle Mals und Moor. Was war deine Lieblingsfolge Podcast-Ufo? Die, wo ihr über diese Munden geredet habt. Ah ja. Ehrlich jetzt? Das ist wirklich mal eine Folge gehört? Ja. Das ist ja geil. Ja, ich dachte, ich muss das machen. Du bist großer Fan von Podcasts. Als ich dich beim Niemagazin getroffen habe, meintest du, du bist großer Fan von Podcasts? Ja, ich höre immer WTF mit Marc Maron und WDR-Presseshow. Oh, die reiten Welt hin, du! Für die Frau von Welt, Comedy and politics. Ich finde es so geil, dass WTF eigentlich länger dauert auszusprechen, die Abkürzung dauert länger als WTF mit MarcTF with Marc Maron. Ich sag immer WTF. WTF, ja, ist nicht schlecht. Das ist besser. Das ist gut. Du redest generell sehr langsam, auch als du beim Neo-Magazin warst, dachte ich, boah, redest du langsam, aber vielleicht auch, weil ich sehr schnell rede. Das ist aber auch einfach eine Taktik, wenn du mit Leuten redest, die in ihrer Comfortzone sind, was ja Jan ist in seiner Send Sendung, dann musst du langsam reden, um den aus dem Konzept zu bringen. Es strahlt auch so eine enorme Ruhe aus. Allein langsam reden zeigt, dass man einfach weiss, was man tut und einfach sehr ruhig in dem ist. Und man nimmt anderen so, man bringt andere so ein bisschen aus dem Konzept, warum ist die so ruhig, die ist ruhiger als ich, obwohl ich hier jede Woche bin. Also das ist jede Woche bin. Also ich meine, dafür, dass du einfach nur einen Gehirnschlag hattest und einfach ein bisschen langsamer bist, das ist halt schon beeindruckend, was das für einen Effekt hat. Das war einfach nicht so wow, aber das war echt interessant, also beeindruckender Auftritt beim Neo Magazin, dass du da so lässig und ruhig da da sei. Vor allem auch immer ein Gag rausgehauen, aber du hast auch ja durch deine Taktik, ich unterstelle dir meine Taktik, hast du mehr Zeit darüber nachzudenken, was du als nächstes sagst. Ja, die aber nur was bringt, wenn man auch tatsächlich die Zeit zum Nachdenken nutzt. Für was nutzt du sonst die Zeit in deinem eigenen Kopf, wenn du gerade nicht nachdenkst? Ich höre euren Podcast. Stell dir an, was ich mit euren Munden gemacht habe. Das war wirklich... M war alles im Mund.
Aber was wolltest du noch sagen? Ich weiss es nicht mehr. Siehst du, du müsstest langsamer denken und dafür präziser. Du holst mich gerade aus einer Comfortzone, die nie eine Comfortzone war. Schon defaultmäßig bin ich hier so aufgepeitscht und nervös und jetzt holst du mich noch da raus und ich noch an einen unangenehmeren Ort. Ich habe ja gerade in zwei Zügen ein Glas Wasserlehrle getrunken, ein wenig ist völlig aufgewacht, schwitzt am ganzen Leib, überall rinnt ihm die Poren, der Poren, der süße Poren saft die Glieder herunter, das ist kaum mit anzusichern. Am Ende dieser vierstündigen Podcast-Folge wirst du dich in einer Comfortzone wissen wie Florentins kalte Decke. Wie hast du das geschafft, in eine Comfortzone zu kommen,, wie hast du es geschafft diese innere Ruhe zu gewinnen? Warst du früher mal anders oder warst du immer schon so? Erfolge früher, du bist dreizehn Jahre alt gefühlt. Ich bin elf. Sorry. Siehst aber aus wie dreizehn. Sie sieht selten aus. Sexy elf. Ich liebe elf. Ich finde elf ist das neue dreizehn für mich. Aber auch 11 ist ein interessantes Alter. Also wenn es noch so mehr als eine Olympiade dauert, bis die legal sind, dann ist es für mich so der Sweet Spot. Das ist für mich so der Sweet Spot. Das ist für mich so... Das ist für mich... Abgeschmeckt, ganz abgeschmeckte Kinder. Wenn die Zellteilung genügend fortgeschritten ist, dass sich der Anus vom Rest schon gespalten hat. Aber der Rest ist noch nicht da. Der Rest ist noch nicht da. Ich muss euch ganz kurz in mein Wochenende entführen. Ich bin mit dem Zug hierher gefahren. Also das letzte oder das nächste? Das ist die letzte Woche. Und ich bin da mit dem Zug nach Köln gekommen, ganz in Ruhe. Und dann war eine Familie, hat sich neben mich, ich war mit einem Vierer, zum Viererplatz gesessen, da kam eine Familie, eine schwarze Familie, eine schwarze Frau und zwei Kinder. Das ist nicht relevant für die Story, aber die waren schwarze, warum soll ich nicht sagen. Und dann haben sie sich zu mir gesetzt und die Kinder, die haben kein Gefühl für Nähe und Fremde gehabt. Und ich war Menschen noch nie so nah in meinem Leben. Also ich war auch, glaube ich, noch nie einer Frau so nah wie den beiden Kindern. Die waren einfach, die haben meine Beine umarmt und so.
Und ich habe diese neuen, das war schon wirklich gruselig,
dann hatte ich diese neuen Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer und ich war wie in einer eigenen Welt so.
Und ich war auch so ruhig und es war so laut und alle waren am Schreien, es war warm,
aber ich hatte immer die Musik und es war alles ruhig und dann dachte ich mir,
eigentlich egal, die könnten mich auch ungebührlich anfassen,
wäre mir eigentlich egal.
Normalerweise wäre ich ausgetickt, aber nicht da in der Situation.
Du bräuchtest so Kopfhörer für deinen Berührungssinn. So Touch-Canceling. Das ist aber eine, glaube ich, Plastikfolie, die man um sich verringert kann. Das ist Winterjacke. Bist du jemand für die kalte Jahreszeit? Wie? Für die kalte Jahreszeit? Bist du jemand für die kalte Jahreszeit? Ja, jetzt tut er wieder so, als wäre ich behindert. Dabei ist das einfach nicht die Sprache, auf der ich aufgewachsen bin. Das stimmt. Ja, ich mag kalte Jahreszeiten sehr gerne. Ja, ich auch lieber, aber das ist ganz seltsam. Wenn die Bettdecken so kalt sind, das ist schön, das ist ein Rundsprassensystem. So ein bisschen Kühlsinn. Aber zum Thema Noise-Cancelling-Headphones, die habe ich ja auch. Und mir ist gestern etwas Interessantes passiert. Ich habe gestern versucht, meinen Fahrradschlauch zu wechseln. Und erst mal die Situation stockendunkel, mitten in der Nacht bin ich rausgekommen, meinen Fahrradschlauch zu wechseln, unter der Laterne. Und dann waren da lauter Infanten um mich herum, die mit ihren Lampen in der Hand durch die Gegend gewetzt sind. Also ein riesiges Remmidemmi, ein Buhai-Sondergleichen, die haben gerattelt mit ihren Ratteln und mit ihren Klabautermännern sind, die durch die Gegend gewetzt. Ein grosses Tohuwabohu Kinder waren am Start und irgendwann kam das Ordnungsamt vorbei. Anscheinend wurden die gerufen, weil es die Ordnung nicht mehr... Weil jemand Schlauch wechselt in der Nacht, verdächtig. Jemand die Ordnung und dann konnten die halt nicht wirklich was machen, das ist halt dann so, weißt du, du kennst es ja, irgendwie deine Elfjährigen sind wieder aus dem Keller ausgebrochen und du denkst ja, okay, jetzt schau ich mal vorbei, um da irgendwie für Ordnung zu sorgen, dann stehst du da auch rum, wie bestellt und nicht abgeholt und stehst erst mal dumm da und so standen dann diese beiden Ordnungsamtbeamten da. Stehst auf dem Schlauch. Das ist die Hazelburger-Garantie. Das ist die Ablaufgarantie, danke schön. Dafür haben wir sie eingekauft. 10.000 Patreon-Peld. Ja, auf jeden Fall standen dann diese beiden Ordnungsamttypen gelangweilt neben mir und einer hat angefangen, mir zu leuchten, einfach weil er überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte, hat angefangen mit seinen Taschen zu leuchten, während ich da wie so der letzte Vollidiot mit ohne Werkzeug, irgendwie ohne passendes Werkzeug da eine Schraube rumgefummelt. Ich hatte die Kopfhörer auf, weil ich einfach schön Bramsey hören wollte, ich nenne ihn Bramsey, während ich einfach bei meinem Schlauch rumgefummelt habe.
Und da fummel ich an meinem Schlauch rum und dann kommt der Typ und leuchtet mir die ganze Zeit. Das ist einfach brutal unangenehm, wenn du da stehst und an der Schraube rumfummelt, während der Typ einfach die ganze Zeit da steht und dir leuchtet. Das war sehr unangenehm. Und dann sind die irgendwann weggefahren und dann kam noch Murat vorbei, ein alter türkischer Mann, 70 Jahre, Türke, kam angewackelt und hat versucht mit mir zu reden und wollte mir helfen, dabei den Schlauch anzubringen. Und hat auch erst mal angefangen, hat mir irgendwie groß und breit erzählt, wie man das machen muss und wie er hergekommen ist und auf welchen Flössen er gearbeitet hat. Und ich habe ja kein Wort verstanden, weil er kein Deutsch gesprochen hat. Auf jeden Fall kurz... Was ist das Wort Flos? Lange Geschichte, kurz, er hat auf jeden Fall mir geholfen, den Schlauch reinzustopfen und war total nett und wollte mir helfen. Ist ein Euphemismus, Schlauch reinstopfen? Rad aus der Hand genommen und hat immer den Schlauch mit voller Wurde unter den Mantel gestopft. Und der Schlauch war halt zu gross, der passte halt nicht unter den Mantel. Dann hat er irgendwann den Schraubenschlüssel genommen und hat den Schlauch mit ganzer Kraft unter den Mantel geschoben. Also hat er wirklich alles gegeben und auch mit einer Frequenz, wo man sich denkt, er ist 70, aber der hat einfach gehämmert, als gäbe es kein Morgen. Und die Kinder haben dabei geleuchtet. Und hat diesen Schlauch unter den Mantel gestopft und dann wollte ich den Schlauch aufpumpen und dann war der Schlauch leider gerissen. Dann hat er ihn leider durch seine gutherzige Art, dadurch, dass er mir eigentlich nur helfen wollte und durch seine herbe Art den Schlauch reingestopft hat, hat ihn leider kaputt gemacht. Und dann war er völlig mit den Nerven am Ende und war völlig enttäuscht, weil er mir helfen wollte und dadurch meinen Fahrschlauch kaputt gemacht hat. Aber das ist interessant, weil die Leute sagen ja gerade, die Gesellschaft, meine Gesellschaft sagt ja, die Flüchtlinge kommen her, die sind total scheisse alle und die machen alles kaputt, die sind nicht scheisse, machen aber trotzdem alles kaputt. Ja, war auch kein Flüchtling, aber trotzdem guter Punkt. Und was hat das mit Noise-Canceling zu tun? Ich hatte die ganze Zeit die Noise-Canceling-Headphones an, es war unangenehm, weil wenn du mit jemandem redest... Das war ein Haar im Bart, warte ich mal. Dankeschön. Und auf jeden Fall, irgendwann kommt der Punkt, wenn du merkst, okay, der Typ geht nicht mehr weg und steht neben dir und spricht dich immer an. Irgendwann musst du die Entscheidung treffen, jetzt nehme ich ab, aber dann gibst du selber auch die Aussage, ich möchte jetzt mit dir reden, die du vielleicht aber gar nicht reden möchtest. Das ist so eine Talfahrt zwischen wie unhöflich kann ich sein bis wie viel ist es mir meine eigene Privatsphäre wert, weil irgendwann triffst du die Entscheidung, dann nimmst du es ab und dann ist aber auch Polen offen und dann labert der erstmal die ganze Zeit. Es war dann schwierig. Ja und je nachdem hast du die auch nur in einem Ohr, damit sie nicht runterfallen, wenn du nicht so ein Clip-on hast oder die so innen. Ja das sind also Kopfhörer mit Bügel. Ah, es gibt ja auch In-Ear-Noise-Cans. Nee, das ist wie so ein Hell. Ich denke mir auch, wenn ich jetzt so eine, also ich finde Ohren abzukapseln ist schon was Heftiges. Wenn ich jetzt so eine Augenbinde hätte und mir hätten Kinder rumgefummelt an meinem Bein, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich gesagt, Moment mal, was ist denn jetzt hier gerade los, bitte, lass das mal sein, aber wohingegen wenn man Ohren, also wenn man Ohren bedeckt, Ohren sind nicht so wichtig, man hört. Hättest du auch nicht gewusst, dass die schwarz sind? Nee, das wäre dann komplett irrelevant gewesen. Ja, aber man hört das vielleicht auch. Ja, und man hört ja immer noch was. Ich glaube, du kannst ja den Ohren nicht komplett abkapseln, deswegen hört man immer noch was und man geht davon aus, dass wenn ich jetzt wirklich den anbrüllen würde, würde er es schon merken.
Ich war mal in Berlin, in einem Club, wie man so ist und er war in der Zeit.
Und da war es tatsächlich so Usus, dass man auf der Tanzfläche, wenn man mit jemandem reden wollte, dann zu dem hingegangen ist und den Finger ins Ohr gesteckt hat bei der anderen Person und ihm dann ins Ohr gebrüllt hat. Weil anscheinend durch die Schallwellenübertragung, durch den Finger besser funktioniert als über die Luft. Ey, du fette Schwein, nimm den Finger aus meinem Ohr, das haben die Leute gesagt. Nein, aber es war wirklich so. Und dann irgendwie war ich da auch da, und dann kamen einfach drei Leute an und haben mir einen Finger ins Ohr gestauft und wir wollten irgendwie Drogen verkaufen oder so. Und dann bin ich einfach fluchtartig gegangen, weil das ist die absolute Hölle, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Also es wirklich schrecklich. Und dann war ich mit einem Freund da und dann wollten wir Frauen aufreissen und der so, ja komm, sprich dich an, aber hallo, hast du einen Schaden, also geh zu dir hin und steck dir einfach mal meinen Waffelfinger in den Mund. Ja, vor allem nach der dritten Frau hat ja dann die erste auch den Ohrenschmerz von, also die dritte hat ja dann viel mehr. Das ist dann komplett egal, man tauscht das, glaube ich. Das ist ja furchtbar. Aber ich habe Ärzte nicht ganzstanden, aber es ist doch so durch sämtliche Körperflüssigkeiten übertragbar. Ja, aber bei Speichel ist es irgendwie sechs Liter oder so. Neun Liter. Neun. Okay, und Ohrenschmalz? Ja, 18 Liter. 18 Liter. Also du müsstest 18 Liter Aids konsumieren. Aber da braucht man schon so einen Trichter. Du müsstest 18 Liter Ohrenschmalz konsumieren, damit du eine realistische Chance hast, dass Aids übertragen wird. Aber muss das dann auch übers Ohr reinkommen oder ist das dann das ganze Konsumiert wieder? Nein, also du kannst es auch vorne durch den Schaft. Ohrenschmalz. Ohrenschmalt. Es ist übrigens für die Hörer zuhause, hallo, es ist ganz interessant, dass dieses Studio, ich möchte die Anführungs- und Schlusszeichen nicht explizit erwähnen, dass dieses Studio extrem gut isoliert ist, aber das Fenster ist auf Kippe. Ich meine, was ist denn das? Wir gehen sehr viel zielgerichtet aufs Ziel, biegen dann aber kurz vorher falsch ab. Das ist ein bisschen unser Ding. Und es ist schön, wir sind auch hier drin, nur aus dem Grund, weil es so schön schallisoliert ist und das eigentlich immer frei ist, dieser Raum. Aber die Wände sind schön kuschelig, aber es ist einfach dann auch zu warm hier drin, wenn man das Fenster nicht aufmacht. Ne, es hat auch was mit Frischluft zu tun. Wir dachten uns, okay, wir sind zu dritt hier in dem engen Raum, sind uns recht nah. Wie viele wart ihr mal? Als wir angefangen haben, waren wir sieben. Sieben Leute, als wir angefangen haben. Die fünfste gestorben leider. Die haben wir umgebracht, weil das so ein lustigsten ... Nee, die wurden dann aussortiert. Also wer nicht genug Gags gemacht hat, dann lief es nicht immer so ein Counter im Hintergrund. Aber ich dachte, wer zu viele und ihr seid jetzt so die frustrierten Zweite zurückgegeben. Nee, nee, wir sind die mit den meisten Gags. Also wir lassen natürlich jetzt nach, aber die, die weniger Gags gemacht haben, die sind durch so eine Falltür runtergefallen, so ein Krokodil-Bag. Aber wegatmen ist ein guter Punkt, weil wenn du was riechst, dann wird ja irgendwas von dem Gegenstand, den du riechst, übertragen. Ich habe dann ein Kacke-Molekül in meiner Nase, wenn ich das rieche. Ja? Ja. Aber es ist ja irgendwann weg, weil Informationen müssen ja irgendwie von dem Gegenstand zu dir gelingen. Du, wo lange Kühle, kannst du wechatmen. Das heisst, irgendwann hast du irgendwas weggerochen. Also wenn du so einen Kinderriegel da liegen hast, und du riechst oder ein Kind und du riechst so oft genug dran, deswegen, Leute, riecht nicht an Kindern, weil die haben nicht so viele Moleküle, die laufen dann mit ihren, sagen wir jetzt mal sieben Molekülen durch die Gegend und dann nimmst du da einen guten Zug, dann sind die fünf Stunden weg und dann hat sie noch zwei und dann wird es irgendwann mit den Wasserschlossverbindungen kritisch. Babys riechen ja eh mega gut. Deswegen aufpassen. Ja wirklich, das sagt man immer so, aber ist das das eigene Baby? Findet ihr das auch? Vielleicht sind das nur Frauen, die das gut finden. Aber so ein Baby im Nacken riechen, puh! Man will das so richtig inhalieren. Addiktiv. Aber wonach riecht das denn? Also kannst du das beschreiben? Nach Sex. Ich glaube, das riecht. Nein, das riecht nach diesen... Nein, nach Sexualdrang. Das weiss ich nicht. Also man hat dann das Gefühl, man muss jetzt ein Baby machen. Ich zumindest. Aber ist das nicht konterintuitiv, wenn schon ein Baby da ist, dann noch eins zu machen? Nein, das ist ja nur ein fremdes Baby. Ach so, also die biologische Eifersucht. Ich habe noch nie an meinem eigenen Baby gerochen, ich rieche nicht dran. Naja, das schaue ich auch nicht an. Nee, aber schaue ich nicht an. Also ich finde, es riecht einfach sehr nach Cremes, die haben halt diese sehr wohlriechenden Cremes und dieses Puder und diese ganzen Parfüren. Wenn du das vorher eincremst. Dieses Diesel-Parfüm, was man einsprüht, damit die gut rieiechen. Wie man cremt das ganze Baby ein oder was? Only the babe. Man cremt das ganze Baby ein. Ja, was meinst du, wie rutscht das raus? Das ist eingecremt. Du musst es eincremen und dann kommt es raus aus der Frau. Und dann wieder rein. Das muss ja jede Nacht wieder rein. Ja, damit es dann noch besser geht. Ja, das ist so wie Zahnseide. Was meinst du, bis zu welchem Alter erinnert man sich an die Geburt? Bis wenn du drei bist, kannst du dich dann noch daran erinnern? Nee, drei Minuten würde ich sagen. Drei Minuten? Ja, ich würde sagen. Und dann ist alles weg und denkst dir, what the fuck? Was ist gerade, what is this? Nee, das denkst du eben nicht, weil du vorher auch nicht weißt, was davor war. Du weißt ja nicht, wenn du dann raus bist und kannst dich an die Geburt erinnern, kannst dich aber nicht mehr erinnern, was davor war die ganze Zeit. Also wenn du das Wort fuck gelernt hast, hast du what und the schon wieder vergessen. Ah ja, aber eigentlich, es ist ja so wie wenn du irgendwo aufwachst und nicht weißt, wo du bist. So ist ja eigentlich das ganze Leben, weil du dich nicht daran erinnerst, wie du auf die Welt gekommen bist. Das ist eigentlich, das ganze Leben ist ein grosses what the fuck, wo bin ich, weil du nicht weißt, wie es angefangen hat. Du kannst dich zumindest nicht mehr daran erinnern. Ist das Leben gerade für dich ein WTF, wo bin ich eigentlich jetzt gelandet?
Das geht.
Du kannst dich schon zu den letzten Jahren zurück erinnern, aber nicht ...
Ich war nicht so nicht konfident, als ich hier reingekommen bin.
Also mittlerweile zweifle ich an meiner Urteilsfähigkeit.
Ich kann mich an vieles erinnern, aber nicht an die Geburt.
Nee.
Woran kannst du dich noch erinnern?
Mach mal Top-Drei-Erinnerungen.
Top-Drei-Erinnerungen sind also ich glaube, eine ist, dass sich mal mit fünf in der Schweiz gibt es, also in Köln ist ja Karneval, ja, ist wahrscheinlich der beste Karneval der Welt, muss man ja sagen, wenn man hier ist. Und in Basel, in der Schweiz gibt es ja auch Karneval und dort ist es so, Tradition angeblich, dass dort so Männer …
Dass die Frauen vergewaltigt werden.
Ja, das auch, und dass aber Männer mit Rucksäcken die Kinder in ihre Rucksäcke stecken und dann so mitnehmen und das ist eine meiner Erinnerungen und das fand ich so schlimm. Kinder in Rucksäcke mitnehmen. Der war als Baum verkleidet und hat mich in einen Rucksack gepackt. Ein Mann, der als Baum verkleidet war, hat sich in seinen Rucksack gesteckt und dir gesagt, das ist hier Tradition. Ja, genau. Und wir dachten so,
oh scheiße, ich war nicht nötig. Schau mal, ich habe ein Kätzchen in meiner Hose. Nicht blöd, da wo viele Bäume
sind, sich als Baum zu verkleiden, um Kinder zu klauen, finde ich clever. Das ist besser als
die Perverse nie. Sind in der Schweiz mehr Bäume als in Deutschland? Und mehr Perverse? Also
da so absolut sicher nicht, weil die Schweiz viel kleiner ist als Deutschland,
aber prozentual. Pro Kopf? Per Kapita? Per Kapita wahrscheinlich schon. Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Deutschland, aber prozentual zur Fläche. Pro Kopf, per capita? Per capita wahrscheinlich schon. Jetzt erzähl mal ein bisschen von der Fauna der Schweiz. Per capita. Wie muss man sich die Fauna in der Schweiz vorstellen? Was sind so die Highlights? Also was vermisst du? Murmeltiere everywhere. Murmeln. Echt, wirklich? Hast du Murmeltier? Murmeltier, ja. Überall. Die grüssen dich jeden Morgen. Machen so Eisskulpturen. So was sehr, was es geht. Was ist, grüezi sagt man, ne? Grüezi. Grüezi. Das war gut. Das war nicht schlecht. Das ist auch das R, das Zungen-R, grüezi. Grüezi miteinander. Grüezi miteinander. Grüezi. Grüezi. Grüezi. Und das scharfe ch, das ist hart, nach. Nach. Wie klingt denn Deutsch für einen echten Schweizer? Also Schweizerisch klingt halt so rückständig irgendwie dumm, aber wie klingt denn für einen Schweizer, wenn man jetzt Deutsch hört, als du es noch nicht gesprochen hast, oder lernt man das schon von Kind auf parallel, Deutsch und Schweizerdeutsch? Ja, halt wie Hitler. Ja, der ja auch Schweizer war. Der war Ostschweizer, ja. Das sind die schlimmsten Schweizer. Starke Ostschweizer. Ach, die schlimmsten. Ja, nee, ich habe ja eine deutsche Mutter, deswegen ist das für mich recht normal, dass die Leute so reden. Und dein Vater war dann Belgier, mit dem Ding ist dann Schweizer. Ach so. Nee, der Vater kommt aus Zürich, also ein Schweizer. Zürich. Zürcherischer. Zürcherischer. Ja, vergess das, das war kein Wort. Was, Zürcherischer? Ein Zürcherischer. Zürcherischer. Zürcher, ein Zürcher. Ja, Zürcher. Aber du kommst auch aus Hamburg, Oder wo? Nee, Dortmund. Dortmund, die Ecke. Dortmund. Dieser Zwang, dieser Zwangseinfälle. Und du? Woher kommst du? Ich komme aus der Nähe von München, aus Bayern. Wo denn in Bayern? Ebersberg. Ja, aus dem Meer von München. Ah, cool. Ist es, glaube ich, im Osten, oder? Es gibt gar schlechte Bier nicht. Halbe Stimme. Ich sag euch, weil. Es gibt gar schlechte Bier nicht, weil auch jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein gutes Bier zu brauen. Perfekt. Absolut. Das war genial. Na ja, Hazel. Ja. Du bist echt mega jung. Wie bist du jetzt eigentlich schon so früh in diesem Medien-Heifischbecken geklanger? Ich meine, das ist ja... Ich verspecke mich immer so hinter dem Wien. Man sieht dich gar nicht, weil der ganze Pop-Schutz davor ist. Aber sag doch mal, wie konnte das denn passieren?
Weiss auch nicht.
Weil ich denke auch immer, warum bin ich jetzt nicht? Ich bin auch 22, wie du. Wann hast du Geburtstag? Am 5. August, 94. Hey, dann bist du ja noch viel jünger als ich. Ja, ich bin noch ein bisschen jünger als du. Ich habe im Dezember Geburtstag, 93. Wikipedia sagt März. Sagt Wikipedia. Weiss ich nicht, kann gut sein. Du hast einen Wikipedia-Eintrag und du habe eben, weil du sehr viel zu spät gekommen bist, acht Stunden sitzen lassen. Ich habe eben bei einem anderen Wikipedia gefunden, und zwar irgendwie so ein... Inklopedia. Genau, Inklopedia, was es gibt, weil die verhindern wollen, dass Seiten aufgrund von fehlender Relevanz gelöscht werden. Deswegen haben die Inklopedia für alle Entdeckungen. Für die, die bei Wikipedia rausgeschmissen werden. Aber du bist weder bei Inklopedia noch beim richtigen, habe ich gegoogelt. Und du? Ich hingegen acht Beiträge, mal angefangen von mir, aber du hast bei beiden. Aber du hast sie selber gemacht? Nee, wollte ich immer mal, aber ich habe nie zu Ende gemacht. Aber du hast bei beiden einen Eintrag, du bist für beide wichtig genug. Ja voll, das ist ziemlich krass. Das ist krass, mit 22. Ja, hatte ich schon glaube ich mit 21. Aber ist jetzt zu spät, weisst du jetzt, 21 bist du nicht mehr. Aber wie ist es mit deiner Karriere gelaufen, also irgendwie hast du das Gefühl, du hast hart gearbeitet, du hast alles ins Zoll gelegt, du hast deinem Ziel hinterher gelaufen oder hast du eher so das Gefühl, rumgereicht zu werden, so dieses, ach wir laden jetzt ein New Magazine ein, auch eine Frau werden wir ganz gut, ach wir haben alle durch, die schon lustig sind, jetzt komm, diese Hazel ist ganz gut, laden wir die mal ein. Wir fragen immer, bist du der Talentierte, bist du der Ehrgeizige oder bist du so eine Mischung aus beidem oder bist du der Glückliche? Also ne, der Glückliche bin ich nicht. Ich bin so, also der Glückhabende meinst du? Ja, oder die Glückhabenden. Ja, ich habe auf jeden Fall viel Glück, aber ich mache halt seit ich siebzehn bin gar nichts anderes, als auf irgendwelchen Bühnen stehen und irgendwas machen. Und deswegen ist es schon fleissig, aber schon auch Glück. Und ja, ich meine, eine Frau zu sein hilft ja voll. Ja, ist das wirklich so? Also hast du das Gefühl, dass du da Vorteile hast? Ja, denke ich schon. Also man hat natürlich auch Nachteile, aber man hat sicher auch Vorteile. Also nur im Showbizisten jetzt. Es ist halt echt scheiße, wenn ich dann so eingeladen werde ins Neo Magazin und dann so überall hinmenstruiere. Das ist furchtbar, da musst du dir erstmal hinten da erwischen. Als Jan da auf dem Blutklumpen ausgerutscht ist, oh! Ich glaube im Autorenraum so an der Decke sind immer noch so einzelne Flecken dran. Ja, und diese so blaue Fäden, so Tamponfäden in den Ventilatoren. Da muss man erstmal furcht durchwischen. Das ist halt schwierig zu sagen, weil man immer, also immer wenn man sich selber in einen Kontext mit anderen versucht zu setzen, merkt man, dass man ja sich selber nicht mal in den Kontext mit sich selber setzen kann, weil man einfach keinen Vergleichswert hat. Das, meine Damen und Herren, war der schlauste Satz jemals in diesem... Ich habe ihn aber leider nicht verstanden. Ich habe ihn auch nicht verstanden, deswegen versuche ich jetzt gerade so eine lustige Überleitung zu machen zu einem anderen Thema, weil ich war dem Satz intellektuell nicht gewachsen. Moment, also du wirst in den Kontext der Weiblichkeit gesetzt und... Und auch einen Kontext mit anderen Leuten, die Ähnliches machen wie ich, aber ich weiss ja gar nicht, inwiefern ich das mit anderen Versionen von mir selber vergleichen könnte. Also ich weiss ja immer nicht, was würde denn eine weniger fleissige Version von mir schaffen oder was würde eine Person, die genau so ist wie ich, aber sich halt vorgestern entschieden hat, irgendwie mehr Dekolleté zu zeigen oder so, was würden die Versionen von mir schaffen, das wäre ja sicherlich eine fetzige RTL-Show mit grossen Hazel-Buchstaben im Winterland. Ja, stimmt, hätte ich halt mal. Und geilen Shiny-Floor und coolen orangenen Schrift und so. Ja, hätte ich ja machen sollen. Ja, das wäre es gewesen. RTL, 22,15. So spät, das will ich gar nicht. Ich will eigentlich so, dass es vor 21 Uhr kommt. Hast du für dich einen Begriff gefunden, was du bist, was du machst? Also wenn mich jemand fragt, was machst du für einen Beruf, dann sagst du, ja dies und das, ich hatte mal so eine Internetshow und jemanden abgesetzt, dann habe ich das studiert und das, wirklich studierst du Philosophie?
Ja, also ich meine, ich gehe nicht hin, aber ich bin eingeschrieben.
Technisch gesehen.
Das ist clever, wegen NRW-Ticket und so, kannst du kostenlos Ruf haben.
Ja, aber ich bin in der Schweiz, ich studiere in der Schweiz.
Ich kann gar nicht was los.
Was ist dein Lieblingsschweizer Philosoph?
Markus Werner.
Was ist dein Lieblingsfinnischer Philosoph?
Was ist dein Lieblingsdeutscher Philosoph?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage, weil sie ja tatsächlich viele Antworten geben kann. Stiss nicht, so Schopi, Nici, Hegi, Arthi, Hegi, MC Hegi. Ja, voll, aber die Österreicher sind eigentlich die Coolen. Aber ihr könnt gerne über was reden, was euch interessiert.
Das ist wirklich was deine Lieben.
Also ich mache jetzt mal ein Wasser auf.
Möchtest du auch noch ein Wasser haben?
Komischer Vibe hier in diesem kleinen Studio.
Ja, sorry.
Wir haben nicht so oft gestiegen.
Wir sind echt gerade einfach ein bisschen fertig.
Wir haben jetzt gerade Frisbee gespielt.
Frisbee gespielt, wir sind völlig fertig.
Wir haben uns überhaupt nicht vorbereitet.
Wie lange dauert denn das eigentlich?
Was denn?
Frisbee-Spiel? Nee, heute hier das. Ach so ein Stündchen. Ach, wir sind fast durch. Ach echt? Ja, macht dir keine Sorgen. Okay. Nein, nein, ich find's ja eigentlich ganz nett. Ich höre wirklich auch gerne Podcasts. This American Life höre ich auch gerne. Ach cool. Hört ihr auch? Ja, Serial habe ich von denen gehört. Ja, das ist auch super. Aber was ist eigentlich mit Edna los? Das frage ich mich sehr lange. Haben die den Fall jetzt neu aufgerollt? Da hieß es doch mal, die rollen den Fall neu auf. Ja, ist glaube ich nichts mehr passiert. Aber da hieß es doch mal, dass sie das neu aufrollen, haben sie auch mal so ein Update gemacht und jetzt gar nichts mehr. Kann irgendwas rechtliches sein. Das merkt mich immer so. Die schmeissen sich da rein und schmeissen mich damit auch in diesem Fall und ich begeister mich dann dafür und lerne die Leute zu lieben und zu schätzen und was passiert mit den Leuten und dann nichts mehr. Also geht es um den Inhalt von Serial. Ja, das verstehen die Leute, glaube ich nicht. Aber dann ist irgendwann vorbei und die erzählen nicht mehr darüber. Und man hört noch so ein paar Medien, die genauso reingeworfen wurden in dieses Adnan-Becken wie ich, finden das auch noch cool, aber danach hören die einfach auf und das ist doch scheiße. Ja, natürlich ist das scheisse. Aber. Was will man machen?
Was will man machen? Ja, Dokumentationen sind schwierig. Also ich habe mal so eine Bären-Dokumentation gesehen von so Bärenbrüdern und die haben sich dann so an der Mutterbär festgeklammert. Und da war dann immer die Mutterbär und dann diese beiden Bärenbrüder hingen dann an der Mutter dran. Die waren Zwillinge, gleich alt. Ja, aber von verschiedenen Vätern. Aber die hingen dann so an der Mutter dran. Und dann irgendwann haben anscheinend das Dokumentarteam, hat anscheinend diesen Bär aus den Augen verloren und hat den irgendwie Wochen später wieder gefunden, aber dann hat ein Bär gefehlt, einer von den kleinen Bärchen. Oh fuck. Und dann hatten die aber halt die Bilder nicht. Ja, dann kann man ja bei Photoshop immer drauf. Ja, Spiegel. Die Paint haben die halt frame für frame dieses kleine Bärchen auf die Bärenmutter drauf gemalt. Haben sie das wirklich? Und haben halt dann gesagt, so ja, der ist irgendwie runtergefallen und hat sich verletzt und sieht jetzt ein bisschen anders aus irgendwie. Und das war halt irgendwie offensichtlich, dass auch die Bärenmutter... Der ist jetzt zweidimensional. Das war halt ein grosser Smiley bei der Alpen. Ja, das war halt irgendwie so ein Kleinwüchsiger in so einem Kostüm, der halt dann durch den Schnee gerollt ist. Und das war halt irgendwie albern, weil man halt offensichtlich gesehen hat, dass die einfach den Bär aus den Augen verloren haben. Aber du kannst halt schlecht irgendwie für 10.000 Dollar nach Kanada fliegen und den Bär filmen und einfach sagen, so nach 20 Minuten, ja, sorry, der Bär ist weg. Hier kommt noch zwei Folgen Family Guy, ansonsten wir sind raus, macht's gut und wir sehen uns dann bei Eisbären vielleicht nächstes Jahr, ciao. Das ist ja auch voll scheisse, wenn du kleinwüchsig bist und dann so eine Schauspielkarriere hinlegst und dann musst du sowas machen. Also du willst dann eigentlich einfach so ein ganz normaler Schauspieler sein, so der Daniel Day-Lewis in Kleiner und dann musst du so einen scheiß Bären spielen, der sich an seiner Mutter festhält. Ja, aber ich stelle mir das mal extrem unangenehm vor, auch manchmal irgendwie so bei verschiedenen Drehs gibt es ja auch Frauen, die ihre Brüsse zeigen Und dann musst du halt extra bei so Schauspiel-Talentagenturen anrufen und sagen, hallo, wir suchen zwei Frauen, die ihre Brüsse zeigen. Und es gibt in Filmen oft Leute, die fetten sind, also wo im Drehbuch nichts anderes stehen kann, als ein fetter Mann betritt die Bühne und das ist dann der Gag in dem Moment. Da frage ich mich mal, wie suchen die, geben die dann den Namen irgendwie Bernd und so und die definieren nie, dass er fett ist? Wie suchen die dann so jemanden, der gerade oder so vorher nachher, also wer spielt dann den, der vorher der hässliche Part ist oder so? Das finde ich immer ganz seltsam. Aber tatsächlich, also die Frage ist halt auch, ob der Gag ist, dass sie fett sind, weil es gibt bei The Office zum Beispiel auch so eine Szene, wo er so ein Blind Date hat, aber nicht weiss, wie die Frau aussieht und dann sitzt er da so da und wartet und dann kommt halt so eine fette Frau angewackelt und er so, oh Gott, bitte nicht. Und dann läuft die aber vorbei und dann ist es eine andere. Mit einer grossen Nase. Und das ist halt der Gag. Genau. Wie werden die gecastet? Also liest die das Skript auch? Also liest sie, dass der Gag ist, dass sie fett ist? Ja, aber das weiss sie doch. Also ich meine, Hollywood ist ja nicht komplett unaufgeklärt. Also die Leute checken ja schon, dass sie keine Hauptrolle finden werden, wahrscheinlich, wenn sie nicht amazing aussehen. Und dann denken sie sich halt, ja, da bin ich halt fett. Haben wir mal irgendwann ein Skript geschrieben und da habe ich das dann für einen Comparison umgeschrieben, das Skript, weil es so demütigend war, was danach kommt. Da habe ich das Skript dann noch mal ein bisschen umgeschrieben und habe dem dann so eine harmlose Variante gegeben, das weiß ich noch. Das sind die harten Tricks, mit denen man beim Fernsehen arbeitet. Das ist nicht immer alles nur Bären, das ist auch manchmal fehlten Bären. Ja, aber es gibt ja auch tatsächlich Talent, also Modelagenturen, die einfach hässliche Leute im Repertoire haben. Weil manchmal, da gibt es so eine grosse Werbekampagne auch, wo die nur hässliche Models genommen haben, irgendwie so als Statement oder was auch immer. Und da gibt es halt wirklich eine Modelagentur, die halt sagt, wir haben einfach hässliche Menschen im Repertoire. Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Models sich fühlen, ob die da sagen, weil hässlich, die sagen das natürlich nicht hässlich, die sagen jetzt nicht, du bist scheisse kackhässlich, du dummes Stück Speiner. Aber die sagen halt dann ja so Charakterköpfe oder irgendwie Missgeburten oder sowas in der Richtung benutzen, einfach damit man da ein bisschen besser drauf klarkommt. Aber im Allgemeinen weiß jeder, dass da halt einfach potthässliche Menschen unterwegs sind. Und man sagt, wir hässliche Leute. Also, wie sind die an diesen Job gekommen? Hat ein Freund gesagt, hey, pass mal auf. Du bist echt so outrageously hässlich. Nee, hab ich noch dran gedacht. Das ist das perfekte Gesicht für unseren Film, den ich gerade im Kopf habe. Ja, wie kommt man an diese Leute ran? Du kannst ja schlecht in der Fußgängerzone Leute ansprechen und anfummeln und sagen, hey, hast du Bock auf ein Fotoshooting, du bist richtig scheisse hässlich.
Ja, Freunde von Freunden wahrscheinlich sind das dann so.
Dann sagt dann so einer so, boah, ich kenne einen, der ist so
hässlich. Ich glaube, der hat Zeit.
Wer ist die hässlichste Person in deinem Umfeld?
Also, wo du dich wirklich
darauf zeigen könntest?
Mit dem, oder der ich regelmäßig abhänge?
Oder einfach kennen?
Nee, aber einfach sagen könnte, wo du die Telefonnummer hast, wo du jetzt einen Kontakt herstellen könntest.
Ah, okay, Telefonnummer, das wird schwierig. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ich suche eine richtig hässliche Person, wen könntest du mir nennen? Das ist wirklich interessant. Das ist echt eine gute Frage. Man umgibt sich nämlich nicht mit, glaube ich, mit Leuten, die man hässlich findet, oder? Ja, oder eben besonders, damit man sich besser fühlt. Also ich hatte. Er hat auch lange keine dicken Freunde, das ist mir sehr spät, du warst mein erster dicker Kumpel. Du bist ja überhaupt nicht so gut, oder? Nicht mehr, aber er wie ein Stück Butter. Wie viel hast du gewogen? 119. Einfach richtig, richtig Brummer. Damit haben wir in diesen Raum, hätten wir zu zweit nicht reingepasst. Aber cool, wie hast du denn abgenommen? Ich habe das Gegenteil von dem gemacht, was ich jetzt seit den Tagen wieder mache. Ich habe aufgehört, so viel zu fressen. Und jetzt nehme ich wieder zu. Das ist jetzt so ein Problem, jetzt geht es wieder aufwärts und das ist hart.
Wie lange hast du gehabt zum Abnehmen? Ein halbes Jahr oder so bin ich dann... Oh, das ist aber nix. Ja, von 119 auf 85. Das war ja genau in der Sommerpause, war ein riesen Skandal, er war plötzlich einfach ein Strich in der Landschaft. Ja, ich habe dich ja nur nach der Sommerpause kennen gelernt als Attractive Person. Ja, aber das ist halt so, wie du in einem Krieg warst und dann nach Hause kommst und weisst, es geht wieder los, so Erster, Zweiten Weltkrieg, so, boah, eigentlich haben wir das hinaus. Und dann kommen die, ach, die wollen das noch machen, oh nö, und dann weisst du, du weisst ja schon, was dich erwartet, und dann gehst du dahin zurück und weisst ja schon, was auf dich zukommt, was ja vielleicht noch schlimmer ist, oder nicht? Weiss nicht, da habe ich jetzt deine Meinung gar nicht auf dem Schirm zu dem Thema, ob eine Gefahr schwer zu ertragen ist, die man schon weiss, worum man sich einlässt, oder ob man naiv reingeht und dann überrascht wird. Da können wir später privat auch gerne nochmal drüber reden. Aber da war es dann so, dass wenn du jetzt fetter wirst, dann weisst du genau, okay, scheiße, ich weiss, was auf mich zukommt und das ist dann noch schlimmer. Ja, und du bist dann auch immer nicht nur der Fette, sondern der Fette, der mal nicht fett war und es dann auch noch nicht geschafft hat. Das ist wie der Typ, den jeder kennt wahrscheinlich, der irgendwann sagt, hey Leute, ich bin schwul und zwei Jahre später sagt, nee, ich bin noch nicht schwul. Wer kennt ihn nicht? Ich habe mindestens neun solche Leute. Weil du dir denkst, was war denn da los? Das Coming in ist viel schwerer als das Coming out, dann zu sagen, ich bin doch nicht schwul. So und das ist das Problem von Leuten, weil du fühlst dich ja erst, sobald du ein Kilo abnimmst, fühlst du dich fett, weil du dann weisst, dass es deine eigene Entscheidung ist, wie fett du bist. Du nimmst dich halt immer so als fett wahr, wie man denkt, ja gut, ich bin halt Deutscher, ich bin männlich, ich bin fett. Das ist so eine Kategorie, so bin ich halt. Aber sobald man abnimmt, fühlt man sich selber dafür verantwortlich und erst dann fühlt man sich fett. Dieses Transgender-Phänomen, dass man sich fühlt, wenn ich mich fühlen würde, als wäre ich eine Frau und dann irgendwann vielleicht diesen Wunsch mir erfülle und dann so eine Frau mich umoperieren lasse. Gibt es das auch mit anderen Situationen, als ich immer schon fett sein wollte? Das gibt es tatsächlich. Also mein Vater ist Neuropsychologe und der arbeitet mit Leuten, die gerne amputiert werden. Das habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Ist das ein Schweizer Ding? Ich glaube, es gibt so diese Spezialkliniken in der Schweiz, die das machen dürfen und so, was überall mega verboten ist.
Nein, aber mein Vater ist da gerade am Forschen dran. Also er ist eigentlich so der Einzige, der das erforscht auf der Welt. Und der Einzige, der erforscht, wie gut Schokolade schmeckt. Aber kann man da seine Meinung grob so einfangen im Sinne von, er hält es für eine psychische Störung und Krankheit, die man heilen kann, oder sagt man ja, lass sie einfach amputieren, dann sind sie glücklich? Ist das wie Homosexualität oder wie Aids? Also dass man vom einen das andere kriegt. Ne, also das ist jetzt eine schwierige Frage zu beantworten. Er hat kein Handy, aber... Und keine Arme. Er hat jetzt Beine als Arme, aber er sieht echt fantastisch aus. Gibt es Leute, die vier Beine haben? Das gibt es sicher nicht. Das ist total cool, die können schnell laufen. Ne, ich glaube, die können gar nicht schnell laufen. Aber ganz kurz, also kennst du seine Meinung dazu?
Man redet ja bestimmt auch über dieses Thema.
Wir reden nur über dieses Thema.
Also heilen, ich meine, heilen kann man das nicht, weil auch vielleicht nicht wirklich ein Heilungsbedarf besteht. Er ist sich nicht sicher, ob das nicht auch durch die sozialen Medien und durchs Internet und dadurch, dass man einfach viel darüber redet, noch verstärkt wird, was natürlich dann dagegen spricht, dass das irgendwie angeboren ist. Aber es ist halt schwierig. Moment, also man kann ja vieles auf die soziale Medien und Medien schieben, aber dass man kein Bein mehr haben möchte, die Wohrkommt. Flache Portemonnaies werden mir oft angeboten und willst du nicht im Körperheilungs werden. Endlich dein Scheiß. Das sind die zwei Dings. Neun Kilo abnehmen in vier Minuten. Nobose, die neuen Kopfhörer, ganz oft, aber kein Bein. Was haben soziale Medien mit Amputationsdienst zu tun? Naja, wenn du, sagen wir, du wohnst in einem Dorf in Russland und hast kein Internet und du hast irgendwie das Bedürfnis, dein Bein zu amputieren und dann sagst du aber so, ah okay, das ist total wieder die Natur, ich werde das nicht weiter verfolgen, diesen Wunsch. Dann ist es so, wie das bis jetzt immer war, also dass das einfach nicht besprochen wird. Wenn du aber dann eine Dokumentation schaust, wo über Leute geredet, genau, podcast UFO dazu, dass es das gibt, dann sagst du so, ah, ich bin wohl nicht alleine, es scheint mir ein Wunsch zu sein, dem es nachzugehen sich lohnt und dann ist das natürlich was ganz anderes, wenn du einen Wunsch hast, wo du ganz konkret sagst, ah, das ist ein Weg, den man gehen kann, dann gehst du ja ganz anders an das Thema ran, als wenn du einfach sagst, das war ja ein komisches Gefühl.
Also die alte Theorie, wenn ein Amokläufer ist, so ein Amokläufer, weil er seinen Zugang zu einer Waffe hat. Ja, genau. Und das ist ein Element, aber das andere ist halt, dass er versucht, diesen Leuten zu helfen, weil das Problem ist, dass ganz viele jetzt so nach Thailand gehen und dann dort so einen Motorradunfall oder so etwas haben und dann so einfach für 10.000 Euro. Motorsägen und Fall. Seit acht Jahren jammerst du über dein linkes Bein und jetzt hast du einen Motorradunfall und gerade dein linkes Bein verloren. Genau, und es ist nicht nur das linke Bein, sondern es ist dann extrem präzise. Also es kann dann so sein, dass man sagt, okay, auf der linken Seite vom rechten Oberschenkel ist es dann fünf Zentimeter vom Knie entfernt und dann wandert es runter auf zwölf Zentimeter vom Knie entfernt. Nein, ernsthaft? Doch, es ist extrem präzise. Und das kann man dann dem thailändischen Arzt dann einfach so anzeichnen? Das weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich schon. Also ich meine, wenn du dem Geld gibst, musst du ihm halt genügend Geld nehmen. Aber man kann sich da so ein Homer-Simpson-Profil nachzeichnen auf deinem Bein. Wenn du willst, ja. Hey, aber ganz kurz mal eben. Also was stört dir dann das Bein, was sie haben? Also stört dir dann, ich hasse meine Warde, meine Rechte, oder sagen die, ich will so sein wie mein Kumpel von mir, der hat kein Bein? Das ist auch eine gute Frage, aber es ist nicht, ich hasse dieses Bein, sondern es ist einfach, es gehört nicht zu mir. Es ist einfach, es ist das Gegenteil von Phantomschmerz, wenn du amputiert bist. Also wenn du einen gesunden Arm hast und dann verlierst du den, dann hast du ja oft Phantomschmerzen und denkst, du hast die Hand noch. Und das ist genau das Umgekehrte, dass du eine Hand hast, die du aber nicht als deine akzeptierst. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als würden die da nichts spüren oder irgendwie, dass die auch körperliche Beschwerden haben, sondern es ist einfach ein psychologisches Ding, dass sie einfach denken, das ist nicht mein Bein. Und die binden das dann zum Teil hoch und wollen einfach so nicht leben. Aber es ist zwar nicht mein Bein, aber Gott sei Dank habe ich dieses Bein, auch wenn es nicht meins ist, hilft es mir am Gehen. Ja, aber ich meine, dann könntest du ja auch sagen, Männer, die eigentlich gerne eine Frau wären, würden sagen, buh, also es ist schon blöd, dass ich ein Mann bin, aber dafür kriege ich kriege ich 12% mehr Lohn. Ah, ja, das ist, ja, weiss ich nicht, Transgender, kriegen die weniger Lohn? Ja, also als Frau kriegt sie weniger Lohn als als Mann. Ja genau, aber die können ja sagen, eigentlich bin ich ein Mann. Ja gut, dann haben sie aber richtig, ja ja. Sneaky, okay, das ist natürlich, da muss man aufpassen. Auch Frauen, Als Frau kannst du ja sagen, ich bin eigentlich ein Mann.
Eigentlich bin ich ein Mann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich glaube, wenn du so gewitzt bist, um das durchzuziehen, dann kriegst du eh nicht weniger Lohn.
Nee, das kann gut sein.
Verrückt.
Aber es ist natürlich, also an sich ist da, finde ich, überhaupt nichts Schlimmes daran, dass man sagt, ich will kein Bein, ja, dann machen wir es ab, okay, cool.
Blödheit nur, was ich mir denn immer denken würde, wenn man dann halt es am Ende bereut und sagt, scheiße, das war jetzt eine dumme Phase, nur weil ich diese eine Folge Fringe gesehen habe, bin ich da irgendwie auf die Idee gekommen. Und jetzt habe ich mir das Bein und die Nase und jetzt ist es halt blöd. Ich denke mir, bei jedem Tattoo, das ich sehe, bei jedem Tattoo denke ich mir, du wirst es früher oder später bereuen. Und dann hast du ein geringes Problem, als wenn dir irgendwie deine alle vier Arme fehlen, dann ist es natürlich blöd, aber kommt das denn vor? Also da würde ich mich informieren. Das ist so wie, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel Fallquote? Ich glaube, das gibt es nicht, gibt es, also ich bin mir da nicht sicher, ich müsste da nochmal nachlesen und das ist natürlich auch ganz oft so, dass es dann einfach nicht dokumentiert ist, gerade wenn das so shady Umstände sind, dann ist es nicht dokumentiert, aber es gibt eigentlich keine, ja, also die müssen natürlich dann schon sehr, sehr sportlich sein. Das ist ja auch, man denkt ja immer, jeder Behinderte kann bei den Paralympics mitmachen, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht. Die sind auch schon sportliche. Ach so, ja gut, sehr klar. Aber niemand denkt, dass man es einfach auf das. Sich einfach an die Ziele in die Stadien stellen, so ich mach mit! Angenehmlich wäre der achtzigste Stabhochspringer, aber mit der Höhe wäre ich der drittbeste Paralympics-Stabhochspringer, würde ich mir überlegen, jetzt weiss ich nicht, was die für eine Behinderung haben im Speziellen, was auch generell sehr random ist, aber dann würde ich mir doch ein Bein amputieren lassen und dann sagen, gut, dann bin ich halt der Beste. Aber ein Bein ist natürlich in dem Fall jetzt schwierig, also bei Hochschwur. Wenn wir hier mal dieses Cyborg-Ohr vielleicht, einfach ein Ohr amputieren lassen und sagen, ich bin Künstler, ich höre den Start schon irgendwie erst vier Minuten später. Aber ist es, das ist auch so bei den Paralympics, dass dann irgendwie, dann spielt Tischtennis ein Blinder gegen jemand, der im Rollstuhl sitzt. Ja, und Sprints machen nur Downies. Aber ist es ein bisschen Unf, das ist mega random, also sorry, weil wenn ich sprinten kann mit einem fehlten Ohr und dann sehe ich die Downies den Hundertmähnstil machen, das ist ja immer sausend, dann denke ich mir auch, warum dürfen die jetzt, warum dürfen jetzt die Affenmenschen, warum dürfen die jetzt laufen und ich als auch Behindter bin die, wie man dann sagt, warum darf ich nicht laufen? Also das ist doch auch, je mehr Leuten, je mehr gutes du Leuten tust, desto mehr schließt du auch automatisch damit aus. Das ist ein großes Problem, wenn du nicht zu allen nett bist, bist du zu manchen scheiße. Es ist ja irgendwie vor allem diese Dualität, behindert und nicht behindert. Behinderte an sich haben ja auch noch eine große Vielzahl. Da musst du dann eigentlich sagen, Paralympics für Blinde, Paralympics für den, den der kleine Finger fehlt, eine linken Hand. Ja, Paralympics für Arschlöcher, Leute, die einfach nicht nett sind. Ja, oder Tiere auch einfach mal. Warum nicht eine Olympiade der Tiere starten? Das gibt es doch so einen Cartoon, den habe ich immer geschaut. Aber nicht in echt. Nicht in echt. Das ist gezeichnet. Aber den Cartoon gibt es schon. Ich will jetzt nicht deine Illusion kaputt machen, aber das ist nicht echt. Da spielt dieser Bär mit, den sie verloren haben. Aber es gibt aber auch eine Olympiade der Tiere, wo das ein Echtfilm ist. Ja, stimmt. Ah, von Disney. Wo da so ein grosses Rad und dann kommt immer Wasser und dann läuft er runter und dann hört das Wasser auf und dann läuft er wieder hoch, um das Rad anzustossen. Der langweilste Film, ne, das war jetzt nicht zweieinhalb Stunden lang, aber ich habe gelacht und gelacht und gelacht. Du bist eher einfach ein fröhlicher Typ. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe mir hier im Schlaf gelacht. Könnte man angenommen, wir drehen einen Film irgendwie, wo die ganze Zeit nur so einen Ventilator... Wir haben einen Film gedreht, Stefan. Angenommen, wir drehen einen Film, wo die ganze Zeit nur so einen Ventilator dreht. Wo die ganze Zeit so einen Ventilator, die ganze Zeit von links nach rechts, so einen 90 Grad Winkel geht. Und man zeigt das dann im Kino wirklich mit, also vielleicht mit einem coolen Trailer sogar. Und dann sehen das Leute, wie lange, glaubst du, dauert es, bis alle den Saal verlassen haben? Das ist gut. Ich glaube, je nach Saalgrösse. Es kommt natürlich darauf an, wie viele Leute dort sind. 80.000? 80.000 Leute wird garantiert jemand den ganzen Film anschauen. Die Frage ist, ob man sich erfrischt fühlt. Wenn du das Bild siehst von dem Ventilator, will ich an, ob du dich dann auch... Es könnte auch sein, dass es gerade umgekehrt ist, dass du dann wie, also sein Körper dann so das Gefühl hat, ich müsste mich jetzt erfrischt fühlen, wieso fühle ich mich ... So wie Süßstoff. Süßstoff, genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, Cola Light macht ja manchmal dicker als normale Cola, wenn man dann danach erst mal den Hunger angekurbelt hat. Aber das denke ich mir, also das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, Hazel, ganz toll. Danke. Das denke ich mir auch, also die Idee von Süßstoff ist ja, dass es genauso schmeckt wie Zucker, aber keine Nährwerte hat und dadurch der Körper sagt, ja Leute, jetzt freue ich mich hier aber auf einen schönen Döner und das war jetzt so einer von diesen scheiß Süßstoffdönern, ich krieg die Nährwerte nicht, aber wenn du einfach Kinder von klein auf, von Kindesbein, von Kindesfuss auf nur mit Cola Light behandeln würdest und die nie echte Cola trinken, dann würden die diesen Reflex ja nicht entwickeln, oder? Das ist ja ein hormoneller Reflex, das ist ja nicht Konditionierung. Also Konditionierung ist dann, dass du das trotzdem kaufst, aber das ist ja rein ein biochemischer Prozess. Also die Lebensmittelindustrie macht ja nicht Konditionierung, sondern die verarscht ja einfach deine Reflexe. Naja, Moment, es ist aber auch so, also zum Beispiel habe ich mir erklären lassen zum Thema Gallensteine, dass das Problem ist, dass versteckte Fette, dass wenn du ein Butterbrot hast, dann siehst du das Fett, die Butter und dann sagt der Körper, ah ja, gleich geht's wieder, gleich stopft er sich wieder den halben Sack Butter ins Gesicht und dann kann der Körper aber so Säuren bilden und so und dann passt alles. Wenn du jetzt aber so Chips isst, die in so einer Tüte drin, oder es ist dunkel und du isst ein Butterbrot im Dunkeln, dann checkt dein Gehirn das nicht. Und dann ist das Problem, dass das Fett nicht verarbeitet werden kann. Aber das ist ja auch nur Konditionierung, dass dein Körper checkt, ah, weisse und gelbe Masse. Ja, Blinde sind komplett verloren. Gelbe Masse ist gleich Fett. Wenn du das anders konditionieren würdest, dann würde es ja auch anders funktionieren. Ja, also du meinst, der Stoffwechsel beginnt vor dem Mund. Ja, das ist meine Theorie, die ich heute so in Stein wie die meisten haben möchte. Der Stoffwechsel beginnt vor dem Mund. Ich kann nicht sagen, wenn man dann kurz ein Video sehen könnte, wo alle Bilder ganz kurz gezeigt werden, von Dingen, auf die sich der Körper gerade vorbereiten kann. Guckst du dir mal kurz an, das dauert fünf Sekunden, alle Bilder hat er unterbewusst wahrgenommen, auch von einem Stück Butter für dich, ganz viele Sachen. Und dann bereitet sich der Körper auf alles vor, automatisch, und dann kann man alles essen. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass es so ist. Ja, auf jeden Fall ist es auch gesünder, wenn du selber kochst und dann so den Prozess miterlebst und riechst und dann dich so darauf vorbereitest, oh, jetzt wird gegessen, aber wenn du einfach eine Packung aufmachst und dann tausend Kalorien, dann ist es schlecht. Wie ist du, Machst du viel selber, auch wo du jetzt gerade nach Köln kommst? Da gibt es viele Lieferdienste, Lieferheld, Pizza.de, Lieferando, Foodora, Deliveroo, Patreon. Ja, ich esse mal bei Spotify, aber dann kommt Werbung. Ich koche sehr gerne selber. Und was machst du dann so? Weil ich habe drei Rezepte auf Lager, eins davon die Spiegeleier und dann... Mit einfach Blanko oder... Ja, Blanko, haue ich einfach rein, acht, zehn ins Gesicht, schieb ich mir. Und dann frage ich mich immer, ist es gerade so gut oder soll ich nicht einfach was bestellen, weil es wird ja auch... Andererseits werden meine Rezepte dadurch ja nicht mehr. Und was machst du dann selber? Rotierst du dann oder bist du so flexibel, dass du alles einkaufen kannst und dann daraus irgendwas zaubern kannst? Ja, ich versuche schon das so zu üben, dass ich alles aus allem machen kann, aber ich bin eben allergisch gegen Weizen und deswegen kann ich nicht alles bestellen. Also ist das ein Vorteil, würdest du das als Vorteil bezeichnen? Allergisch zu sein? Ja, auch gegen Weizen. Ja, also eigentlich schon, weil es, also natürlich ist es ein Nachteil, wenn man unterwegs ist und dann nichts zu essen findet, aber es gibt nichts. Es gibt Weizenfelder, kilometerweit Weizen. Ja, fast überall hat es Weizen drin, aber auch so versteckt, so in lila Pause zum Beispiel ist Weizen drin. Das ist aber der Cornflakes, packen so unten noch die letzte Geschichte. Nein, aber Cornflakes haben zum Beispiel Weizen. Weizen, Vollkorn hat auch Weizen, Weizen hier, alles noch so ein Cola unten, so die unterste Schicht, einfach alles Weizen. Ja genau, es sind überall Weizen. Man muss ganz schnell trinken. Aber es gibt nichts, was man unbedingt essen muss, das Weizen beinhaltet, deswegen ist es nicht so schlimm. Und das ist dadurch bestimmt eine bewusste Ernährung, weil du dich damit auseinandersetzt, was wo drin ist und dadurch einfach viel lernst. Ich bin gegen Pflaster allergisch und das ist ein riesen Problem und das ist mega unbekannt, weil Leute, auch wenn nicht mit Blut abgenommen wird oder so, dann wissen Leute nicht damit umzugehen und sagen, ich bin gegen Pflaster allergisch und dann gucken die alle verwirrt und machen mir trotzdem Pflaster drauf. Also gegen welchen Bestandteil des Pflasters? Gegen diese Klebstoffe.
Ah Scheisse, und was machst du, wenn du verletzt? Dann müssen sie mir das verbinden und sowas. Aber das ist total seltsam, weil wenn ich irgendwann mal irgendwie gegen einen Baum laufe, was ungefähr jeden zweiten Tag passiert, und dann komme ich ins Krankenhaus und dann wissen die ja nicht, dass ich gegen Pflaster allergisch bin und dann werde ich mit Sicherheit. Ja, dann musst du dir das tätowieren lassen. Du musst dir tätowieren lassen, ich bin gegen Pflaster allergisch. Aber stell dir vor, du verletzt dann genau die Stelle, wo das Tattoo ist.
Ah ja.
Fuck, dann sieht man es nicht und klebt es. Das wäre so ironisch. Aber das ist ja die Frage, ob wenn es dann wieder heilt, ob dann das Tattoo mitheilt. Ja, wenn da ein Pflaster draufgestellt wird, dann wird das nie heilen. Wenn man dann so einen Schnitt macht und das dann so leicht versetzt aneinander drückt, dann steht da Laster. Ich bin gegen Luster allergisch. Da denken alle, oh clever. Oh, das wäre ein Film, das wäre das bessere Mento gewesen. Hezelburger in Ich bin gegen Luster allergisch. In Memento. So ein Anti-Porno. Das finde ich gut. No means no production. No means no production. Du sagst sehr viele schlaue Dinge, die ich irgendwie, ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss nicht wiederholen, um sie einfach nochmal zu sagen. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Was passiert, wenn du ein Pflaster aufkommst? Es kommt so eine ganz widerliche, grosse Ausschläge bildet sich. Auch jenseits des Pflasters? Ja, so um darum, aber schon im Kontext, im lokalen Kontext des Plastik. Und das ist schon immer gewesen, oder?
Ja, ja, das ist schon immer so gewesen. Ganz seltsam, ganz seltsame Allergie.
Auch Kondome, ganz normale Kondome?
Nee, Kondome sind ganz normal. Da ist kein Klebstoff drin, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal...
Also es ist nicht dieses...
Echt?
Nee.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe noch nie Sex gehabt.
Aber du hattest ja auch mit der Perücke grosse Probleme, die dir mal für den Dreh aufgeklebt wurde.
Dann wurde ihm eine Perücke auf dem Kopf geklebt und dann hat er auch Ausschlag im Gesicht gehabt, was mega gut zur Rolle gepasst hat, weil er so einen Heavy-Metal-Techniker-Nerd gespielt hat. Ah, siehst du, und da brauchten sie dann wieder jemanden hässlichen und da haben sie sich getraut. Ja, dann wurde der Titzler wieder ausgepackt, aber das passt eigentlich perfekt. Weil es ist ja auch gut, also als Schauspieler kannst du sagen, ach scheiße, du bräuchstest jetzt mal Ausschlag, dann ja gut, gib mir ein Pflaster, dann kannst du das alles vorrufen. Gib mir so ein gesichtsgrosses Pflaster. Ja, ins Gesicht. Ja, ich hatte auch mal so eine Theateraufführung und dann hatte ich auch so einen Ausschlag und dann zieht sich durch mein Leben. Und dann hat mir die Maske erzählt damals, also die Maskebildnerin, die Maske, das wäre Wahnsinn, die hat dann gesagt, dass der Schauspieler von Gimli, der von Herrn der Ringe auch gegen sein Kostüm allergisch war und der hatte auch wirklich so ein pockiges Gesicht. Nicht, weil er so aussieht, sondern weil er eine Allergie, eigentlich ein schönes Legolas, ein Elbengesicht, so ein Stein gemeißelt, aber er war einfach gegen die Maske allergisch und dann hat sich das gebildet und er hat es einfach durchgezogen. Das ist vielleicht der nächste Schritt der Maskenbildner-Kunst, dass du das gar nicht mehr nachbildest, sondern einfach provoziert hast, die da genau an der Stelle eine Wunder zu haben. Da sind wir wieder bei der biochemischen Konditionierung. Richtig, das ist ja fantastischer, guter Begriff. Oh mein Gott, wir haben Rundfaden zum ersten Mal. Aber abgefahren, abgefahren der Beruf von einem Vater, der Neuropsychologe, der ist schon abgefahren. Hat sich das auf dich abgefärbt oder rebellierst du dagegen gegen diesen Ja, schau mal, was ich mache, natürlich rebelliere wirklich hast du ja ich also ich habe auf jeden fall nicht das studiert was er studiert hat unter anderem weil er das schon gemacht hat ja aber also wo gerade schon war jemand schlaues aus unserer generation da haben was ist eigentlich also warum rebellieren wir nicht mehr gegen unsere eltern das macht doch jede Generation. Warum rebellieren wir nicht mehr gegen unsere Eltern? Ach so, keine Ahnung. Eben, es macht jede Generation. Ich habe nicht das Bedürfnis, bloß zu rebellieren. Alle, die ich kenne, haben das Bedürfnis, zu rebellieren. Manche sind so still. Ist es nicht gerade die Rebellion, nicht zu rebellieren? Also dass die Eltern... Es ist ja immer abwechselnd. Die einen sind die harten 69er-Generationen, Party, Drogen, Sex, und dann die nächste Generation... 68er, oder? Die nächste Generation Im Augenblick können wir noch 69er sagen, weil ich finde da war kein grosser Unterschied, aber die nächste Generation ist dann wieder total bieder, weil das die Rebellion gegen die Eltern sind, das heißt, es ist immer so abwechselnd. Ja, ja, also mich würde auch nichts aggressiver machen, als wenn ich so ein Kind hätte, das dann so voll der Spießer ist. Das würde ich so hassen, das dann so alles macht und immer... Aber du hättest das beste Kind, also du ... Boah, aber ich fände es widerlich. Ja, es wäre mega unsympathisch und wäre weird, aber ... Ja, das ist so Charakter. Weißt du, wenn du ein teures Stück Käse kaufst, um eine Schweizer Metapher zu verwenden, dann willst du einen Käse, der dich auch so ein bisschen zum Kotzen bringt, dann ist der teurer. Ah, guter Punkt, aber ist das wirklich so, ist das das Geheimnis von Käse, dass du sost, aber ich muss auch ein bisschen kotzen. Einfach lange genug warten. Dann unterscheidet es sich von anderen Kindern, wenn dein Kind nicht aalglatt ist. Aber wenn dein Kind so funktioniert, dass es perfekt funktioniert, muss es ja eines von vielen sein, weil perfekt sein können ja alle. Also das ist ja das. Aber ist das nicht die eigentliche Rebellion, genauso zu sein wie alle anderen, den Individualismus abzuschwören, weil jeder will ja individuell sein, aber einfach zu sagen, ich gebe meine Individualität auf. Unsere Eltern waren nicht individuell, waren nicht die Mega-Individualisten, das waren ja auch noch die achtenlässigen. Ich glaube, unsere Elterngeneration ist halt eigentlich sehr glücklich aufgewachsen und auch gesund, auch noch nicht so viel Zucker und Süssstoff und so, aber die haben trotzdem so mit ihren eigenen Eltern natürlich nie über ihre Gefühle geredet. Also ich glaube, das ist die erste Generation, die wirklich mit ihren Kindern über Emotionen redet. Redest du mit deinen Eltern über Gefühle? Ja, wenn wir Gefühle haben. Das ist neu für mich. Redest du mit deinen Eltern, reden die mit deinen Eltern über Emotionen? Ja, schon. Nee, nicht wirklich. Nicht? Nee. Gar nicht. Fragst du ja auch nicht so, wie geht's dir? Doch, aber ich habe nie das Gefühl, wirklich mein Herz auszuschütten. Ach ja, gut, nee, das. Also, also ein Job, so, ich habe heute Podcastaufnahmen. Nee, dafür gehe ich zum Beispiel Podcast-Ufo, um mein Herz auszuschütten. Ja, ich auch. Das ist wirklich hilfreich, so einen Podcast zu haben. Hast du, warum hast du keinen Podcast? Ich meine, wenn du gerne Podcasts hörst und du bist eine eloquente ... Ich glaube, wir treiben das gerade aus, einen eigenen Podcast. Ich hasse einfach so regelmässige Sachen. Also wenn ich dann so denke, oh scheiße, es ist schon wieder Mittwoch, ich muss jetzt einen Podcast raushauen. Das musst du nicht machen. Die Leute werden dich dafür hassen, aber du musst es nicht machen. Irgendwann kommt Stefan Schwier und wird dich hassen dafür. Wir haben auch nicht regelmässig aufgenommen. Ja. Wann kommt das denn? Du hast mich eben, ganz kurz, du hast mich eben auf UCB angesprochen. Auf Bright Citizens Brigade. Auf Bright Citizens Brigade, komm die Konglomerate aus New York. Hast du eben darauf angesprochen. Warst du schon mal da? Nee, ich würde da gerne mal hingehen. Aber bist du so Improv begeistert? Nee, ich finde Improv ist so, wenn Improv schlecht ist, ist es das Schlechteste auf der ganzen Welt. Also dann würde ich mir lieber die Fingernägel rausziehen lassen von jemandem. Das ist wirklich so schlimm. Also so einen Improv-Podcast, den Leute machen, die es nicht so richtig können, würde es dir nicht geben. Das wäre das Schlimmste für dich. Das wäre das Schlimmste für dich. Das wäre schlimmer als sich die Kugel zu geben. Ich habe das so ein paar Mal, ich war 2014 oder so an einem Theater in der Schweiz bei so einer Produktion, die einen Monat lang gedauert hat. Und dann hatte ich immer eine Stunde Zeit zwischen meinem ersten und meinem zweiten Auftritt. Und da war dann im Keller immer Improvolympics. Und das war so schlimm, also wenn dann die Leute so gegeneinander improvisieren, so als Wettkampf, das macht einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und ja, ich weiss auch nicht, also es ist mir zutiefst zuwider. Auf meinem Wikipedia-Artikel steht auch, dass ich bei so einer Schule war, aber das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, das hat mir einfach einer da reingedrückt, weil ich das so blöd finde. Nimm das! Du kannst aber auch löschen. Ich weiss nicht, wie das geht. Bearbeiten, klicken und löschen.
Ich werde das jetzt aus deinem Wikipedia-Eintrag.
Nee, das ist nicht so einfach.
Also wenn das so einfach wäre, dann wäre es ja ein absoluter Grund, dass da überhaupt etwas Richtiges steht.
Vielleicht gibt es das andere Wikipedia, was wir eben angesprochen haben.
Inklupedia.
Ja, aber ich will ja Exklupedia.
Also ich will ja wie Wikipedia exkludierend diese Informationen.
Ein Hazel-Wiki.
Das wäre doch cool.
Nur so Dinge, wie ich sie beschreibe. Und bei ganz vielen Sachen ist dann so, was ist das? Wurde Synthese. Keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert. Aber das ist nicht cool. Schmecken gut, aber wo jetzt genau der Unterschied zu Äpfeln ist, keine Ahnung, frag mich nicht. Sorry, Leute. Messing. Erlkönig, Fragezeichen. Don't mess with the Messing. Viele Fragezeichen. Vielleicht sowas in der Richtung. Wie viele Gedichte kannst du auswendig, Hazel? Gar keine. Kannst du, also wie ist es mit deinem, du bist ja Poetry-Slammer, da geht es ja auch um Lernen und andere bewegen, sich selbst bewegen, sich dazu in Bewegung setzen. Also ich mache ja ein Stand-Up-Programm, ich gehe nicht mehr zu Poetry-Slam. Nee, der abgeschworen, verächtlich. Aber du bist auf bist auf Tour. Was machst du dann da? Ja, 90 Minuten Stand-Up. 90 Minuten Stand-Up? Ja. Okay, und du machst seit wann Stand-Up? Ja, ich habe immer so vor den Slam-Auftritten so ein bisschen Stand-Up gemacht, weil ich keine andere Plattform hatte. Weil 90 Minuten ist eine Menge, ne? Ja. Wie viel lang hast du gebraucht für eine Stunde Material? Für eine Stunde habe ich wahrscheinlich so ein Jahr gebraucht. Okay, krass. Ja, halt dich ran. Wir haben einen Stand-Up-Aufzug gehabt hier in Köln und seitdem nie wieder. Jetzt ist ja im November. Wieso nie wieder? Ich weiß es nicht so richtig. Mir lief es so, dass ich keinen Grund hatte, es lief nicht so schlecht, dass ich dachte, ich muss es unbedingt noch mal besser machen.
Es war aber auch nicht so gut, dass ich dachte, ich brauche das jetzt jede Woche. Also habe ich gesagt, ja, dann lasse ich es jetzt einfach auch. Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall Lust, das nochmal zu machen. Ja, mach es auf jeden Fall, ist doch super, ist das Beste. Ende des Jahres bin ich nochmal im Boeing. Ich glaube, wir sind einfach zu faul. Es war einfach zu viel Arbeit. Ja, ich würde auch gerne mal so an so Open Mic gehen.
Ja, können wir gerne mal machen.
Also hier ist ein, das ist Boing-Ryoing, das ist warm.
Der heisseste Schuppen Kölns.
Da gibt es jedes Donnerstag heisse Stand-Up-Comedy, frisch auf die Pfoten.
Klingt super.
Das ist auf jeden Fall was, wo wir mal hingehen können.
Ja, wohnst du jetzt hier in Köln, fest?
Ja, fest, also ich bin eigentlich auf Tour die ganze Zeit, deswegen bin ich nicht so
oft zu Hause.
Wie ist das Tourleben?
Ja, wenn du jetzt hier, wohnst du jetzt hier in Köln fest? Ja, fest, also ich bin eigentlich auf Tour die ganze Zeit, deswegen bin ich nicht so oft zu Hause. Wie ist das Tourleben, wie ist das auch? Ja, scheisse, also es ist schon okay, aber du bist halt, also ich bin halt 200 Tage im Jahr unterwegs. In Hotels aber, oder? In guten Hotels? Ja, schon. Aber das ist ja schon ganz geil, oder? Ich liebe Hotels. Also man romantisiert das vielleicht so ein bisschen, aber es ist ja schon so Leben auf der Straße. Man romantisiert das leider komplett. Also es ist wirklich, also nach einer gewissen Zeit ist es echt nur noch anstrengend, wenn du dann so im Hotel bist und dann, also es gibt halt wirklich keinen einzigen Tag in meinen letzten fünf Jahren, in denen ich nicht einen Koffer gepackt habe. Und das ist schon anstrengend. Okay, aber irgendwann hast du so eine Routine, ne? Also du kannst einfach, okay, und die Shirts und die Hosen und du denkst gar nicht mehr nach.
Ja, ja, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass man dann manchmal noch Sachen vergisst,
dann muss man ja die ganze Zeit noch schauen.
Also ich muss ja auch immer schauen, wo muss ich wann morgen sein und so.
Das ist schon anstrengend, aber es ist natürlich auch cool und ich müsste das ja auch nicht machen.
Also in Hotels, ich liebe Hotels einfach, weil das Hotel ist für mich der Inbegriff von Luxus.
Du musst, das ist ein Gebäude, was meistens toll aussieht, architektonisch toll, es ist sauber, du kommst da hin und es ist nur für dich gebaut, um eine angenehme Nacht zu verbringen. Und alles ist nur auf Komfort ausgelegt, alles ist nur für dich so. Ich finde das total geil, aber wahrscheinlich mehr. Ja, aber das beste Hotel ist vielleicht Gen vielleicht genauso gut wie zuhause schlafen nach einer Weile. Ja, okay. Weil es halt auch, dass du auch auschecken musst, ist blöd. Dann ist es wirklich auch so, dass man in der, das ist so ein Urinstinkt, dass man an fremden Orten nicht so gut schläft, weil man extra wach sein muss. Ja, weil eine Gehirnhälfte bleibt wach, weil man Angst hat vor Feinden.
Ja, genau. Und das ist halt was. Was auch doof ist, dass man das nicht mehr ausdenkt. Deine Post zu Hause häuft sich halt an, wenn du auf Tour bist. Du kannst halt nicht einfach mal so sagen, ich gehe jetzt jeden Dienstag zum Tischtennisverein. Das geht halt nicht. Das heisst, dein ganzes Sozialleben ist weg. dann wenn du halt Dienstag und Mittwoch irgendwo auftrittst, musst du an verschiedenen Orten um 11 Uhr auschecken und kannst dann aber erst um 4 Uhr am neuen Ort wieder einchecken und musst dich dann in den Stunden dazwischen alleine in irgendeiner fremden Stadt beschäftigen. und irgendwann hast du halt auch dann jede Stadt gesehen und es ist einfach komplett scheiss egal.
Also Louis C.K. sagt das auch mal in so einem Interview, dass die Leute immer sagen so, oh you're in Seattle, you have to go see bla bla bla. Und das ist wirklich mittlerweile, also das ist mir einfach scheiss egal. Das ist mir so egal, was ihr in euren scheiss Städten macht. Wahnsinn, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Du bist zu Louis C.K. Ja. Wie fühlt sich das an? Auch schon cool, oder? Auf eine Art. Du kannst dich mit ihm verbinden, wenn er Dinge an der Doten erzählt. Ich verstehe das irgendwie gar nicht, warum das überhaupt Leute, die das nicht verstehen, lustig finden. Also denen das nicht so geht. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass es lustig ist. Aber die lachen. Ja, aber die lachen ja eh. Also ich war auch in Amsterdam. Echt? Ja, war dort auch. Hättest du dir gefallen? Ja. Ah, cool. Auch Munden, hast du auch Munden gehabt? Ja, klar, ich habe Munden gehabt. Hast du immer noch Munden? Nee. Das heißt, ich habe eine halbe Munde. Punktlandung habe ich gemacht. Wow, nicht schlecht. Ich habe es mit dem letzten Mood, den ich gekauft habe, versaut. Da hatte ich noch eine halbe Munde zurückgekommen und das war dann natürlich zu wenig. Aber du hättest ein paar Süssigkeiten kaufen können. Für eine halbe Munde? Ja, aber es ist ganz komisch. Wenn ich den Plastikbeutel mal aufmache, dann wird ja auch voll gemacht. Okay, da gibt es jetzt keinen, ich nehme mir zwei Fruchtraschis. Ja, das sind ja dann so acht Munden oder so für einen vollen Beutel, weil sie waren mega. Ich habe vier Rechte nicht ganz verstanden. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob man bei einer halben Munde noch Munde sagt oder nicht, sowas wie Cent. Die haben bestimmt auch so ein Cent-Pendant. Ja, aber ne, es ist schon eine halbe Munde, aber ich glaube eine Munde war 1,50 Euro. So was, ne? Also halbe Munde ist 75 Cent. Aber ich fand das ein tolles Stand-up. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du dann die Folge gehört hast, wo ich darüber schon rede. Ich fand das einfach, es waren so zwei Stunden, wo ich einfach, ich habe noch nie so ausgeschaltet, glaube ich. Man denkt ja immer, okay, gleich muss ich wieder nach Hause fahren, wir sind in Amsterdam, aber dann bin ich erst im Zelt zuhause, dann gucke ich noch eine Runde Netflix und dann gehe ich schlafen.
Aber während ich das geguckt habe, konnte ich mich darauf konzentrieren, konnte mich darauf einlassen, ich hätte nicht das Gefühl, an mein Handy zu müssen. Ich habe einfach gelacht zwei Stunden, das war toll, das war eine tolle Zeit. Ja. Fand es nicht so gut? Ich fand's schon gut, aber es war auf jeden Fall auch gut, aber ich dachte eigentlich dann so ein paarmal, ach krass, das ist jetzt einfach so das allerbeste, was Stand-up-technisch geht. Das weiss ich auch nicht.
Und das hat mich dann irgendwie schon so ein bisschen geerdet. Es war aber auch klar, es waren ja so 80 Minuten ungefähr und es war ganz, ganz klar ersichtlich, dass das Special nachher die 60 Minuten, die er da rausschneidet und auch auf seine Webseite stellt, die werden amazing, weil es waren ungefähr 20 bis 30 Minuten dabei, die echt nicht nötig gewesen wären, die auch so ein bisschen.
Denn, ich weiss nicht, es wirkte manchmal so, als wäre das jetzt nicht ein Programm von ihm, sondern als hätte so ein perfektes Autorenteam, das ihn nur kennt von all dem, was er bis jetzt gemacht hat, hätte versucht, etwas für ihn zu schreiben, das so wirkt, als hätte er es geschrieben. Und was auch ganz schlimm war, fand ich, waren die drei Opening-Acts. Ich fand einen von denen mega gut, den letzten. Aber ich weiss nicht mehr warum und ich habe auch keinen Gag mehr von ihm vor Augen und ich weiss auch nicht mehr, wie er hieß. Der hieß Joe Mackey. Den fandest du nicht gut?
Ne, fand ich nicht so gut. Okay, das ist interessant.
Wer ist der beste Comedian in Deutschland, im deutschsprachigen Raum?
Neben Hazelbrugger.
Nein, also ich bin hoffentlich in zehn Jahren mal sehr gut, muss natürlich bis dann noch sehr viel auftreten.
Ja, wer natürlich sehr gut schreiben kann, ist Thorsten Sträter, der ist aber halt kein Stand-up-Comedian. Wer eine unglaublich gute Bühnenpräsenz hat, ist Moritz Neumeyer. Ja, mir weiss ich jetzt leider nicht genau, wer das ist. Und Jan Philipp Zimny ist auch extrem talentiert, weiss man aber natürlich nicht genau, was das ist, was er macht. aber ich weiss nicht. Das heißt es glaube ich nicht, man da. Ja, genau. Glasbleiserei, ich weiss nicht genau. Ja, weiss nicht, es ist schwierig zu sagen, wer ist der beste Comedian in Deutschland, aber ich orientiere mich auch wirklich nicht am deutschen Markt. Also wieso sollte man, das ist halt so, wie wenn man so... Es ist immer so blöd zu sagen, aber es ist trotzdem immer so blöd zu sagen, ach, ich gucke nach Amerika, weil die deutschen Medien... Wieso ist blöd? Also das ist ja wie, wenn du als... Ja, natürlich, das ist so viel Scheme, die sich so... Wenn du Chinese bist und mega gut Fussball spielst, dann willst du doch nicht in Peking Fussball spielen, sondern in Madrid. Dann willst du bei Real Madrid spielen, dort, wo die Sportart herkommt, willst du in besten Klubs... Ja, aber es ist trotzdem nicht... Trotzdem willst du deine chinesischen Vereine unterstützen und trotzdem willst du halt irgendwie, wenn alle sagen, geh nach... das ist da viel besser, dann willst du auch so eine Meinung haben wie, aber hier, du willst halt, wenn du halt, du willst eine sophisticated Meinung haben, gerade wenn du auch aus der Branche kommst und so, dann willst du sagen, okay, aber die folgenden Acts sind ganz geil eigentlich und das kann man viel oft, also selbst die, die es wissen müssen, sagen trotzdem, zählen meistens trotzdem amerikanische Acts auf. Ja, also mein Lieblingsdeutschsprachiger, der ist halt nicht deutsch, aber der ist ein Schweizer, ist Stand-Up-Comedian, ist Gabriel Vetter. Okay. Der macht das halt auf Schweizerdeutsch, aber der wird das, der kann auch gut deutsch, also der wird das hoffentlich auch mal nach Deutschland bringen. Überlegst du manchmal auf Englisch, also so gut Englisch zu können, dass du ein englisches Programm schreibst? Ja, ich kann auch sehr gut Englisch. Also ich habe auch einen amerikanischen Pass. Ach stimmt, du bist in San Diego geboren. Ja, genau. Das ist so lächerlich cool. Das klingt so lächerlich cool. Ich bin mal 20 Minuten aufgetreten in Chicago. Und? Ja, es war super cool. Es hat mega Spaß gemacht. Echt, es ist cool? Und hast du gekillt oder gebombt? Ja doch, es war killing. Oh wow, geil. Warum machst du überhaupt noch was in Deutschland und machst nicht direkt? Also nein, ich meine es war auch natürlich diese Magie vom ersten Mal auftreten und dann irgendwie die Leute wussten so, ah das ist jetzt total speziell für die, dann ja dieser Ausländerbonus, das ist halt, also nur weil es einmal geil war, heisst es ja nicht, dass ich mir das dann die ganze Zeit geben will. Also es ist ja wie wenn du irgendwie ein Gummibärchen isst und dann sagst du, wow, das schmeckt ja super, dann willst du ja nicht den ganzen Tag Gummibärchen essen. Außerdem habe ich ja hier auch ein soziales Umfeld und das ist ja auch mein Job einfach. Also ich habe ja auch Buchungen, ich muss ja da auch hin, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach weggehen. Nee, aber irgendwann perspektivisch. Ja, ich würde sehr gerne mal versuchen, in Amerika ein bisschen aufzutreten. Ich denke, wenn Deutschland jetzt irgendwie wieder Scheiße macht zum Beispiel und sagt, ja wir nehmen jetzt einfach Polen ein. Ja, dann gehe ich in die Schweiz. Ja, dann gehst du in die Schweiz. Also ich zum Beispiel, ich schreibe beruflich Witze und das kann ich auf keiner anderen Sprache. Ich bin verloren, dann habe ich einfach verloren, dann kann ich einfach einpacken, dann kann ich anfangen, Schulen sauber zu machen in Amerika. Aber es gibt ja ganz viele Leute, die auf die Landessprache Deutsch angewiesen sind. Also wenn du Deutschlehrer bist, in einem deutschen System bist du ja auch darauf angewiesen. Ja richtig, genau, aber das ist uncool, also uncool auf eine Sprache angewiesen zu sein. Stimmt das denn, dass die Schweiz so ein Abschottungssystem hat, dass wenn irgendwie die ganze Welt durchdreht, die irgendwie auf den roten Knopf drücken und dann irgendwie alle Brücken gesprengt werden, alle Tunnel einstürzen und die sich komplett abschotten. Gibt es so Gerüchte, dass irgendwie dann überall Brücken schockt. Ja, also ich glaube, die Schweizer haben da schon einiges im Köcher noch, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das dann ... Die essen dann seit dem Toblerone und schmeißen das Papier an die Grenze. Man kann ja zu Fuss über die Grenze, also da ist ja keine Brücke, grösstenteils. Ja, dann sprengen die einfach so einen Schacht und eine Lava. die Schweizer haben auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, die sind sneaky motherfuckers und wenn dann irgendwie irgendwas passiert, dann schauen sie erstmal, dass es dem Land selber gut geht. Aber dann fährst du auch mal kurz in die Schweiz, weil du denkst, dann macht es jetzt, wenn ich hier bin, weil dann bin ich sicher. Das wäre schon cool, wenn die so einen Mauer hochfahren könnten, einfach wie so eine Arena, einfach so eine Kuppel, so eine Glaskuppel. Ja, die mit so einem Spray eingesprüht ist, dass so Ausländer abperlen. Ja, dass man sich selber sieht, so einen Spiegel. Ja, der die Leute noch so fetter macht, damit sie total unsicher sich fühlen. Das ist nicht schlecht. Aber es ist auch das einzige neutrale Land, also da ist Schweiz schon echt abgefahren, sozusagen. Norwegen. Naja gut, aber ja gut, vier. Es gibt schon noch neutrale Länder. Aber was bedeutet das überhaupt? Ich meine, das weiss ja niemand, was das heisst, neutrales Land. Naja, dass wenn die sagen, die einen sagen A, die anderen sagen B und die sagen, ja, sage ich nicht. Ja, aber die haben dann dem A so einen Pinselstrich, damit sie sich das A malen kann, bezahlt. Also die sind da schon mit drin. Spürst du das denn in deiner DNA, in deinen Genen, spürst du diese Neutralität, dieses, wenn wir uns jetzt streiten würden, würdest du dann sagen, würdest du dich dann zurücklehnen, schon? Ja, ich bin schon eher diplomatisch. Aber ja. Also ich würde dann nicht so mich zurücklehnen, sondern ich würde dann so sagen so okay, also
nicht streiten.
Du hast, nee, das würde ich auch nicht, ich würde sagen so, du hast gute Argumente, ich verstehe euch beide, aber versuch doch mal dir vorzustellen, weisst du.
Was der andere gerade fühlt.
Stefan, versuch dich mal, so kleine Berge aus Schokolade, versuch dir das mal vorzustellen.
Sein Selbstbewusstsein hat noch nicht abgenommen, also so, weisst du, das ist so immer noch. Man muss dann einfach versuchen, sich auch vor Augen zu stellen, dass ja jede Person, die man überhaupt irgendwo nur sehen kann, die hatte ja schon einen Tag. Also die ist ja schon den ganzen Tag da. Und die hat auch schon... Also du wirst ja auch sagen, Hitler irgendwie dann 1940 sagen so, hey Leute, jetzt hab mal auf. er hat ja auch keinen Stress. Ich verstehe das aber, also ich meine, es ist ja auch mega scheiße, was er gemacht hat, aber ich... Auf einer gewissen Art kann man es nachvollziehen, ja. Ja, und das finde ich auch so... Moment, Moment, also mir fehlen ein paar Sprünge, die jeder gerade gemacht hat. Nein, ich meine, er hat natürlich auch einen Schaden gehabt und irgendwann... Aber wir haben alle einen kleinen Schaden. Aber er war auch so ein bisschen so... Das finde ich auch so das Problem. Das ist ein Typ gewesen. Nicht natürlich das Problem, aber ein Problem von Isis finde ich, dass niemand daran was Positives gewinnt. Also wenn die dann wenigstens so sagen würden, cool, es ist perfekt so wie es ist, wir köpfen jetzt Leute. Es sind wenigstens gerade Schnitte und sie sind sofort tot, das könnte man sagen, aber es ist doch das einzige, die kämpfen für eine Religion, das ist per se scheisse. Ja, aber die wollen Länder einnehmen, die wollen Land gründen, per se eine fragwürdige Entscheidung, wenn eigentlich alle Orte der Welt vergeben sind, dann muss man sich einfach entscheiden. Ja gut, aber irgendwo muss man anfangen. Richtig gut, da fangen sie auch auf dem richtigen Ort an, eine Wüste irgendwo, okay, aber dann schneiden sie Leuten die Kehle durch, sie morden aus religiösen Gründen.
Das ist way too much.
Ich finde, das sind alles Dinge, die sind ein bisschen, oh, da können sie sich mal einen guten PRler holen.
Aber was ist denn das Positive, dass du dem ISIS abgewinnen kannst? Oder sagst du, es ist nicht alles schlecht, klar?
Nein, nein, ich sage, alles ist schlecht und das finde ich eben das Blöde. Also weißt du, ich würde sagen, es wäre positiv wäre positiv wenn wir es scheisse fänden aber sie fänden es so mega geil also sie wären halt so zu 100 prozent zufrieden aber so ist einfach niemand zufrieden und das ist scheisse sie wären auch ein bisschen gruseliger wenn sie noch mal wenn sie auch mal was gutes machen könnten also wenn man nicht genau weiss was machen sie jetzt sie kommen auf die stadt zu sie könnten den careakete geben oder sie könnten sie angreifen und dann greifen sie sie an und säbeln alle die Köpfe.
Dann werden sie noch gruseliger. Element of diffusion noch so mit einbringen. Aber das macht die ja auch so aggressiv. Mecherlich aggressiv, überzeichnet. Sie wollen ja wirklich den westlichen Freiheitssinn angreifen, und das ist doch so blöd.
Also wenn es so einer Hälfte gut geht, wieso muss es denn allen schlecht gehen, nur damit es fair ist? Das ist halt so. Also das ist natürlich jetzt total, das klingt so dumm. Ja, aber es stimmt. Es klingt sehr, sehr dumm, aber es stimmt. Aber würdest du auch sagen, Hitler hatte einfach einen schlechten Tag und würde einfach sagen, so ein Gott. Er hatte eine Reihe, einen schlechten Tag. Das ist ja der, wenn du heisst Jahrzehnt.
Nee, aber ich glaube, er fand es eben auch nicht geil.
Er fand es eben auch echt richtig scheisse selber.
Also weisst du, der hat danach gesagt so, oh, so, Alter, fuck, ey, ich sehe es, ich sehe es selber.
Wenn etwas passieren muss, wenn etwas ganz, ganz Schlimmes passieren muss, und es ist einfach, man sagt es einfach, das muss jetzt passieren, so Fritzl zum Beispiel, eine wird jetzt für im Keller vergewaltigt. Dann ist es doch immerhin noch besser, wenn der, der das macht, das gut findet. Das stimmt. Aber wie viele schlechte Tage muss man denn haben, bis jemand sagt, na gut, du hast es, also du bist wirklich einfach kein guter Mensch. Ich meine, du kannst dich jeden Tag sagen, gut, der ist einen schlechten Tag, der hat es schon wieder. Nein, also außerdem sollte ja deine Wahrnehmung von deinem eigenen Tag null dein Handeln beeinflussen. Also du kannst ja unglücklich sein und trotzdem ein guter Mensch. Aber das ist ja so ein bisschen wie beim Poker, wo du eine gute oder eine schlechte Hand kriegst. Und rein statistisch, wenn jeder Mensch der Welt jeden Tag eine neue Hand kriegt, gibt es halt auch einen, der einfach mal elf Jahre am Stück nur scheiss Hände bekommt. Absolut, dann der hat. Nein, statistisch. Und dann einfach sagst du, ja Leute, irgendjemand muss schuld sein und ich krieg halt immer irgendwie dann halt die Juden so und dann machen wir das jetzt halt. Das ist halt ein statistischer Effekt, dass einfach irgendjemand hat halt einfach einen schlechten Tag nach dem anderen. Ja, die Chance, dass du einen schlechten Tag hast, ist ja auch grösser als dass du einen guten Tag hast, weil du einfach was Negatives viel klarer einordnen kannst, als was Positives. Also du kannst ja beim Negativen ist es ja einfach, es ist ja einfach negativ. Also wenn was Schlechtes passiert, dann misst du das ja gar nicht so, ui, das war jetzt zehnmal schlechter als gestern. Aber bei was Positives machst du das eher, also da machst du dann eher das und sagst so, ah, das ist jetzt zwar gut, aber ich habe mich auch schon mal besser gefühlt. Und hingegen für jemanden, der immer schlechte Karten hat, ist auch so ein Bauer 3 gut. Wohingegen für mich das nicht gut wäre, ich wäre bei einem Astkönig wegzufrieden. Bist du so ein Glückskind? Ja, also weiss ich nicht, aber ich denke schon, so in Deutschland geboren, weiss, wohlriechend, heterosexuell, hasst du alles.
Fragezeichen.
Möchte ich nicht darauf eingehen.
Musst du auch nicht.
Ich will mich in diese Ecke nicht gedrängt fühlen.
Und dann denke ich mir, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich beim Asskönig, wäre ich zufrieden.
Und dann weiß ich auch nicht, was ich dann damit machen würde.
Die Frage ist halt, bei welcher Karte gehst du all in?
Gehst du bei Asskönig schon all in oder warst du auf die nächste Hand, die Ass-Ass sein könnte?
Oder sagst du, ja gut, ich bin schon zufrieden mit Asskönig. Ich gehe eigentlich ziemlich bald all in. Du gehst direkt all in. Nicht direkt. Wenn da irgendwie... Ja. Wenn es die Karte vom richtigen Spiel ist. Uno! Wenn es endlich keine Uno-Karte ist. Mit dem Kniffel gehe ich all in. Du hast recht. Nee, du hast völlig recht. Also das ist... Wenn euch irgendwas Gutes zum IS einfällt, einfach mal irgendwie in die Kommentare hauen, irgendwie irgendwas, was positiv ist. Habt ihr noch Fragen? Okay, wir legalisieren jetzt Drogen. Ich will jetzt nicht das, das ist, was die Leute mitnehmen. Habt ihr noch Fragen an Hazel Brugger, die sie uns beantworten können, dann stellt sie in den Kommentaren. Ruft jetzt an. Ruft jetzt an. Du bist auf jeden Fall jede Woche dabei, würde ich sagen. Puh. Ja, dann nicht. Dann las es halt. Gut, dann eben nicht. Dann halt wieder Florentin und Stefan. Jede Woche kommt die Scheisse. Und das ist jetzt die von kommenden Samstag? Von 76. Du bist jetzt offiziell auf Spotify. Bist du schon auf Spotify? Hast du schon was davor gemacht? Meine CD ist auf Spotify. E Spotify. Ehrlich jetzt? Gut, okay, ja dann. Eine CD?
Also ich habe ein Comedy-Album.
Und die hört ihr euch jetzt schleunigst an?
Ne, das ist Schweizerdeutsch, es kommt aber dann irgendwann noch das Deutsche raus.
Die Untertitel könnt ihr euch ja denken.
Wir kopieren es in der Playlist mit sehr viel Enya und La De Ray.
Und Seal, Kiss From A Rose.
Kiss From A Rose.
Das ist mein Tune.
Crying Aerosmith, die ganzen Sachen.
Song von Seal, Crying Aerosmith, der Song von Seal? Ja, von Aerosmith. Crying Aerosmith, die ganzen Sachen. Song von Seal, Crying Aerosmith, der Song von Seal?
Ja, Crying Aerosmith.
Verstehe ich nicht. Alles klar, gut.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst, Hazel.
Danke, Hazel.
Hey, Hazel, Hazel Five.
Das waren keine Hände.
Alles klar, und am Ende der Folge heben wir noch so ab, bei wem Ufo sind.
Okay, Achtung, wir heben jetzt ab.